we're just two weeks away from the ps5
launch
and guess what the new batch of free
playstation plus games actually includes
a ps5 launch game
here's what you can get your hands on in
november
first up the adorable bug snacks will be
available day one on ps5
as a freebie for ps plusers you'll be
able to explore the island meet its
residents
and catch all sorts of edible creatures
just note that this is only the ps5
version of the game
ps4 players get their own pair of games
as usual
and the first of those is hollow knight
voidheart edition
which includes the critically acclaimed
metroidvania game and all four of its
dlc
packs it's not an easy game but it is a
rewarding one
as you explore the hollow nest fight all
sorts of big bosses
and learn new abilities as the unnamed
knight
lastly ps4 is also getting middle-earth
shadow of war
this is a sequel to shadow of mordor
featuring an even deeper nemesis system
plus a ton of new combat options for
increased battle strategies
this should help tied over lord of the
rings fans waiting for that golem game
and amazon series
and those are your free playstation plus
games for november hollow knight and
shadow of war will be available in the
normal window
from november 3rd through the 30th bug
snacks will be available at the ps5
launch on the 12th
and it'll be free on ps plus through
january 4th
stay tuned to gamespot as we report on
the new ps plus lineup
every month
[Music]
[Music]